hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well it Anselm of
Canterbury
treatise on freedom of choice one of
these central preoccupations is
determining and indeed defining this
this concept of freedom of choice and
it's important to note right from the
start that an sum is not making
assumptions that many other people might
that freedom is something like the
ability to select between alternatives
or to do whatever it is that you want to
do or to be able to put into practice
what it is that you've decided those do
fit within a certain scope of what he
calls ability or power
potestas but it's not the same thing as
freedom Libertas that he's attempting to
define here and his student begins by
asking about this you know Libertas
arbitrary freedom of choice and is
trying to find a definition and suggest
that maybe you know it's going to be or
going to involve the ability to sin or
not to sin that is to have two choices B
for one and he brings us up with in a
theological context saying free choice
seems to be opposed to gray
predestination and foreknowledge of God
I want to know what freedom of choice is
and whether we always have it if freedom
of choice the student says consists in
being able to sin and not to sin as some
persons are accustomed to say in
Anselm's own time and in our own then
you know what's the story he ran some
and and some is the teacher says well
it's it's not that and the student says
well hold on a second
why wouldn't it be or at least involve
the freedom to do one of two things
and so Ansel brings up a very important
consideration that that fits into his
way of approaching these things he says
that to begin with if it was the ability
to sin or not to sin then we'd have to
say that God and the good angels they
don't actually have freedom so that's a
bit of a problem but let's go a little
bit deeper let's think about what it
what the ability to sin would actually
mean sinning is doing something wrong
doing something whether we conceived of
it is like breaking God's law or we
conceived of that in an older sense as
you know committing some sort of offense
doing something in you know unjust
harmful something damaging he says that
if we think about what what goes on with
this he says which will seems to be the
more free to you the will which so wills
and is so able not to sin that it cannot
be turned away from the uprightness of
not sinning or the will which in some
way is able to be turned to sinning and
the student says I don't know I mean it
seems to me like both you know having
both possibilities is really being more
free and then Anselm brings in the
clincher for his viewpoint here he says
when you sin you're doing something that
is unfitting quoted ekit in latin and
dis advantageous known expected
something that's not good for you
something that is not befitting
something that is unbecoming you could
say that doesn't match what it is
that you really do want and intend he
contrasts to that freedom and he says
freedom is actually the the ability to
keep to maintain to preserve what is
befitting codec at what is advantageous
quote expense
what is indeed good for you as a being
so this is how he treats it in Chapter
one a little bit later on in Chapter
three he's going to talk about the
purpose of freedom of choice and he asks
well you know why did they have freedom
of choice he says what end do you think
they had that freedom of choice now the
word end is not actually in there it's
framed in a different way in the Latin
so he says was it in order to obtain
what they will or was it in order to
will what they ought to will and what
was advantageous for them to will so
we've got two different conceptions here
is freedom being given so that they can
will whatever the hell it is that they
want to will and be able to do it or is
it being given so that they could will
what is good for them and what is what
they ought to will and what is
advantageous this is a key dividing
point if you follow Anselm along here
he's going to say that you know we we
can connect all these things together
freedom of choice is for willing what is
befitting and advantageous so that's
going back to that chapter one thing and
what is that and some calls that
rectitude of will rectitude o Volant on
ttis it could also translate it as
rightness of will uprightness of will
whatever it is that you want and it's
good to keep in mind that in the work
just before this and some defines
justice in terms of the moral quality
that we can have and then our action
can have as rectitude of will maintained
for its own sake which is going to come
up a little bit later
so this rectitude of will is doing the
right thing choosing the right thing
choosing rightly and he adds there that
it we have to understand it as being
maintained for its own sake not simply
being maintained for the sake of
avoiding punishment or gaining reward or
you know any other sort of inducement or
reason it has to be there has to be a
recognition that what is good and what
is just is good and just in its own
right and therefore it should be
maintained for its own sake now this
thing that's being maintained is in our
will within us so you could think of
rightness of will as a reflexive use of
the will that maintains that very
rightness within it by choice by free
choice later on in chapters 4 and 12
he's going to say something that that
fleshes us out about freedom of choice
what if this rectitude of will gets lost
through one way or another somebody
abandons it in favor of something else
likes a creature comforts right or the
ability to impose revenge on somebody
else so once that's lost
Ansem says that it can't be gotten back
just by the person willing it back and
at the same time freedom of choice
Libertas arbitrary is still possible for
the person even when they're lacking
that rectitude why because they still
have two important faculties that set us
apart from the other animal creatures
one of these is the Faculty of reason
and the other is the Faculty of will so
rat CO and
Volant us he says that here we go
there there's nothing that that prevents
us from having this uprightness itself
if it can be given back to us there's
nothing that prevents our ability having
prevents us having the ability to keep
up brightness of will for the sake of
this uprightness as long as we have
reason by which to recognize it and will
by which to hold it fast a little bit
later in Chapter 12 he amplifies his
point and tells us that even when
uprightness of will is lacking to us we
have in us the ability to understand and
to will by which ability we are able to
keep uprightness for its own sake when
we have it and better put when we get it
back when we're able to to have it
bestowed upon us in chapter 13 which is
almost the last chapter of the work he
will give us a definition or a hill
he'll maintain that uprightness of will
maintain for its own sake is in fact or
the ability to keep uprightness of will
for its own sake rather the potestas to
keep this is in fact the complete
definition of freedom of choice so he'll
go through a number of different
discussions about this and here we go
and say that the ability is the genus of
freedom so freedom libertas fits under
potestas and then he says the addition
of to keep distinguishes this from every
ability which is not an ability to keep
like the ability to laugh or the ability
to walk we're zeroing in on it further
then keeping uprightness is you know a
distinctive object we're not keeping
gold or whatever is not uprightness and
then of will separates this ability from
the ability to keep uprightness of other
things like that of an opinion or
language and then finally for the sake
of uprightness itself you says this
ability is distinguished from an ability
to keep operating
we'll because of something else for
example keeping it for the sake of money
or because of natural inclination so
what we have here then finally is a
complete definition of what an sum takes
freedom of choice to consistent it's not
the same thing at all as simply being
able to do what it is that you want or
being able to select one of two options
in fact to really have freedom of choice
would mean to reject one of the options
if one of the options is something that
is unfitting and dis advantageous notice
that it does still leave a certain
flexibility and range of options within
the realm of what is befitting and what
is advantageous so this is an Psalms
conception of freedom of choice
you